le 11 mai prochain mes chers
compatriotes sera donc le début d'une
nouvelle étape à partir du 11 mai le
lundi 11 mai jusqu'au lundi 11 buts
[Musique]
à l'évidence je veux le dire cette bonne
méthode sera progressif
[Musique]
nous avons nous demandé à plusieurs
équipes de travailler sur cette question
du déconfinement en étudiants
l'opportunité la faisabilité d'un
déconfinement qui serait régionalisés
[Musique]
à partir du 11 mai nous rouvrirons
progressivement les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
oui l'école est obligatoire c'est la loi
qui le dit en revanche c'est progressif
donc tout le monde n'y va pas tout de
suite
les masques c'est une bataille
essentielle le masque grand public que
nous encourageons fortement
c'est un complément c'est un complément
au bon respect des gestes-barrières j'ai
toujours plaidé pour le l'accès aux
masques grand public
[Musique]